[Music]
[Applause]
oh we always love having jamal crawford
on turner sports nba analyst three-time
winner of the nba sixth man of the year
great score and uh jamal back on the
program jamal how are you how's the
jumper i'm great and it's still there
it's still really
really in motion so could you play right
you're what are you 42 in a week yes 42
in a week could you play right now
absolutely for sure why are you not
playing
that's the million dollar question danis
that's been something that's kind of
drove me crazy for a while it's amazing
when i see guys have high scoring games
40 or 50
and people are like hey that's the next
star i told you he was going to be a
star and i'm like that's true but i got
50 and really couldn't even get a job
the next year and that's kind of
baffling for me as well how old were you
when you scored 50. 39 i was 39 years
old but i did do it off the bench so i
said some juices
but you had to embrace that and i guess
it's hard for today's player to say i'm
i'm not good enough to be in the
starting lineup
but it's not true because you were but
how how did that help your career coming
off the bench as the sixth event well i
think it put
people uh on notice because i was known
as a good player as a bat on bad teams
when i was scoring a lot we weren't
winning a lot and i said you know what
i'll do anything and as faye would have
it i got traded to the atlanta hawks and
they already had their starting five in
place they had been to the playoffs so i
said you know i come off the bench no
problem and it sounded easier than when
i actually had to do it but then when i
had to do it i was like oh i can do this
and i think it extended my career i
think people view me in a different
light and i thought you would need a
player like that to to be a championship
caliber team looking at guys like jason
terry and manoj noble i saw where kyle
korver is working with ben simmons
if you were working with ben simmons
what would you work on
i'll work on the mental part of it first
i would get him in a relaxed place as
far as having fun it's not
life or death i would get him in that
pace whenever he had the most fun when
he was a kid a child and you know when
he's coming up in high school try to put
him in that state as much as possible to
kind of free everything else but i
wonder about
you get into
a fourth quarter and you could almost
see him looking at the clock like it
we're going into fourth quarter i don't
want to be taking shots consciously
subconsciously how do how do you remove
that from somebody who has that much
talent of you want the ball in your
hands in the fourth quarter
i
possibly trick him that's the first
quarter uh deandre jordan
deandre jordan right he
free throws he he would get a little
nervous late in games and i've never
said this before but i would go up and
sing to him you know i would sing a song
to get him to smile and relax before he
shot free throws and in the fourth
quarter i bet your free throw percentage
was a lot higher than it was the first
report paulie checked that what song did
you sing to deandre jordan
he starts singing it with me and then he
starts smiling he asks me about it and
he starts smiling then he relax and
start making free throws oh you know i
was i i start to think about this with
the offense that's played now now we
want to christen uh joel embiid and
james harden is the new shaq and kobe
um how do you you played against shaq
and kobe how do you feel about that when
after what five games we want to say
they're the new kobe in shack yeah
that's the the the area we're in now but
no there's only one shotgun kobe that's
the most dynamic duel i would say ever
potentially as strong as they both were
they won championships so you know they
were able to earn the right of shaq
being shaq and kobe right like you said
five games is
rather soon i think they're both hall of
fame talents i think they're both very
very skilled and very very
good quite honestly but we're a little
early on that that proclamation okay
what happens to harden because he's a
wonderful player fascinating player but
man he can giveth and take at the wage
mall and certainly in the playoffs what
happens to hardin
well i think uh with james especially
his
gift is how intelligent he is a
basketball player but also his other
gift is how free he plays he plays
really free he's at peace with his game
he's never rushing he's never you know
he's dictating everything that's going
on in the playoffs it tightens up and
then they allow you to be more physical
you know one of james gifts is being
able to be a foul magnet right but he
gets fouls in the regular season he
doesn't necessarily get in the playoffs
and sometimes that's an adjustment for
him as well yeah it's just that when if
i was look okay best duo in basketball
right now is who
kevin durant kyrie okay yeah i agree
yeah i agree i feel like they have
mismatches most nights and they both
perform the best on the biggest stages
on the brightest stages just like last
night's game that was a game within the
game for them they wanted to send a
message and they knew the whole country
is watching they knew ben simmons like
come on out ben you can come out and
lick and boo you but we got your back
don't worry about this we got it guy
when i watch durant in transition jamal
seven footer and then he he crosses over
tobias harris and
have you ever seen anybody block durant
shot like jumper
no i have not and the thing about kevin
he's one of the rare superstars in
history who doesn't disrupt your offense
watching him play is like watching the
water come out of a faucet he can play
the catch and shoot game he can play the
pick and roll game he can play the
isolation game he can play the post game
and he always makes the right play and
that's what also makes him so hard to
guard because he's not like oh he's just
going to score he's going to shoot every
time it's like no i'll score you double
team i make the correct pass and people
love playing with players like that
paulie do you have deandre jordan's free
throw numbers first quarter fourth
quarter i kind of have something that
could help jamal crawford's case before
jamal crawford joined the clippers
uh deandre jordan was shooting 38 from
the free-throw line the next year he
went to 43 percent 44 48 with small
crawford on the team
in fourth quarter i guarantee you
so you you played against
pete kobe peak lebron late jordan yes
wizards jordan okay
and how different was jordan as the
wizards
jordan and and the bulls
well obviously
a little bit older but he was still
dominant people forget his first year
with the wizards before he had the knee
injury him and kobe were the only two
guys in the whole league they were
averaging like 25 5 and 5
and jordan was 39 years old so he was
still unbelievably good i had a chance
to train with him coming into that
season
but obviously a little bit older he had
to pick his spots a lot more to save his
injury inner energy kobe was like
nothing i had ever played against
because i didn't see wizards i didn't
see bulls jordan so kobe was just the
talent the skill level the artistry the
mentality he could go over eight and hit
the game winner with like it was nothing
over eight man he was closer to getting
hot he wasn't thinking like he had an
off night right
and then lebron is just
he's a of nature you've never seen the
player that athletic with that kind of
iq his basketball intelligence he's a
chess master he's always moving pieces
always moving across the board always
thinking the game i would say he's
almost like a bigger version of cp when
it comes to how they think the game
their chess masters okay i'll give you
mj kobe lebron in their prime as a
teammate
um
as a teammate yeah
um i didn't play with any one of them
but if you ask me how i viewed them from
as a peer which one would you want as a
teammate
i would say michael okay just because i
feel like he's
he's one of one michael is so great that
when somebody else is great in another
field we say that's the michael jordan
of that i would want to be a part of
that and the bulls are my favorite team
growing up yeah but i would want lebron
if i'm a shooter like you are because
mike and kobe
they're going to cut into your shots
there jamal yeah it didn't say i'll play
with my whole career but i want to go
through that phenomenon i want to see
what that's like i'm a young player
coming in don't forget i came in as a
point guard so i'll be fine with him
we're talking to jamal crawford turner
sports nba enlist three-time winner of
the nba sixth man of the year
were you in the gatorade commercial with
jordan that
you played the how old were you you play
the younger jordan the bulls version of
jordan and he's with the wizards
absolutely i was
22 i believe and i was the younger
version
and i'm like okay what's the lines like
no lines let's just talk play one on one
i'm like there's no lines like so i
started reaching for the ball he's like
you reach i teach you right and he's
he's kind of i'm going out for his flow
i'm like okay am i playing i'm trying to
play like me i'm trying to play just
play and the director that day his name
is joe i forget his last name he
directed space chair
he's like go up and dunk and do that and
mj was like jc doesn't do all that
dunking all right get and then they had
kevin daly uh from the holland
globetrotters who was doing the actual
dunking so i did the one-on-one stuff on
the court talking to him playing
one-on-one and that stuff it was really
really a dream come true i didn't know
then it would be such an iconic
commercial but you know you go home you
tell your boys like hey what'd you do
today um i
i was michael jordan versus michael
jordan
nah dan it was the other way as soon as
i got the car said i'm going to be in
the commercial
[Laughter]
and you got gatorade right and i got
gatorade and i actually got a check from
gatorade i couldn't believe that i was
like i get paid to be in a commercial
with with michael jordan this is this is
crazy
is there hope for the lakers
their best hope
their best hope is that they make the
playoffs i actually think they could
be a better playoff team than they were
regular season team and i believe with
the veterans they have the game slows
down dramatically and the lakers kind of
need that they don't they don't really
enjoy doing extra effort things or
getting out in transition or running
back too much so i think they're
actually built more for the playoffs i'm
just not sure they get there
would you make russell westbrook sixth
man
no i would not do that i would actually
stagger his minutes a lot more like most
great teams do right or when they have
two great players that kind of on the
perimeter i would stagger his minutes a
lot more so he would probably come out
at the eight minute mark let lebron play
the whole first quarter then i bring
back rus the second quarter
with the second unit you know so that's
a way of kind of staggering their
minutes where he gets comfortable being
more the focal point because
westbrook is kind of this is low-hanging
fruit the lakers issues are a lot deeper
than westbrook when i watched him play
but i was staggering his minutes to kind
of put him more in that alpha dog row
when he's out there with the second unit
what are some of the issues that are
deeper rooted than russ
like i said extra effort i feel like
when they're winning they have a lot
more energy things are different when
they're not winning it's like a box
you're going to get hit in a boxing
match if you get hit you know you got to
fight back and when i see them get hit
they don't necessarily always fight back
and and that's kind of the problem ads
not there they have some deeper issues
what's the coolest thing in your office
hmm
my wife got me my first
ever shoes over on you can't see him
right now but my rookie shoes i hadn't
seen him since i was a rookie so she
found those and then i would say the
kobe shoes he actually signed for me and
then the jordan picture right there over
my shoulder that's probably those three
top three okay but if you have to get
out of the house and you take one thing
what are you taking
i'm taking kobe shoes that he signed for
me because i can never get those again
what did he uh what did he write on
there
and i was looking forward to that too
dan i was like what's he gonna say
what's he going to say he said
jamal great competing against you all
these years yeah much much respect and
that for him that was so big because he
thrived on competition we had some great
battles
do you think kobe could be underrated
because he's sort of in between lebron
and mike
yes without a doubt and i think i think
he's a top five basketball player of all
time i feel like you could have dropped
him in any error in his peak and he
would have been a top five basketball
player all the time his like i said his
skill level was out of this world then
he had a shot where he was shooting left
hand like he was shooting even mark
cuban had to stand up like that was just
unbelievable right i mean
he he had 62 and three quarters in the
mass had 61. they said kobe you want to
get 80. he said no i'll do it later
a month later like
he was out of this world good he's the
best like player i ever played against
and matched up against so yeah he he's
underrated for sure and i i hope more
guys who played against him i thought
that he could
i thought he could have scored 100 in a
game because he had the mentality
to do that
and
i mean he got 81
but yeah he wasn't far off
yeah because he would have gotten 80 i
we had dirk nowitzki on earlier in the
week and and he said you know kobe out
outscored us
and then didn't play in the fourth
quarter so he put up 62 and didn't play
in the fourth quarter he said it easily
could have gotten 80 85 in my opinion
man has anybody ever done that and then
to actually go get 80 after that like
his mentality his skill level his work
ethic
mama mentality is is a way of life it's
not just on the court it's how you live
it's maximizing every second to what you
do what your craft is and how you go
about your craft so it's inspiring uh
kobe had a whole different aura about
there could be a room full of stars he
would walk in even the stars like that's
cool
you
know
he had a different different deal with
him although when michael showed up at
this 75th anniversary team oh did you i
tweeted about did you see that
that was okay kobe had a different swag
about him jordan's was the same level
but he had to glow when he walked in as
well it's like is that smoke around that
guy
everything freezes what's going on with
him absolutely that was when the crowd
goes crazy and it's cleveland so this is
lebron's town
mike comes in and all of a sudden uh
lebron who
it's amazing my 11 year old son jj we
watched it and he said look at look how
mj walks in he's i said how do you walk
in he's he walked in like a boss like he
just walked in like like he owned the
joint right
i'm like if my 11 year old son picked up
on that i know the players there did as
well it can jj shoot
oh yeah he can shoot it he can really
shoot he can play he loves the game i
actually coach him and uh this is my
first year doing that i'm having a ball
with it so yeah he can play i know you
uh you live in seattle
is when seattle getting the nba team
here jamal you see my shirt right yeah i
mean it's a little innuendo here we're
putting this out here i like it
i believe in the next five years i
believe the hockey team had to uh come
first and now we got that everybody sees
our fan base you see the storm the
seahawks the mariners
now the kraken we have an unbelievable
fan base people love coming to the city
we're built for it and we'll support it
well so i think within the next five
years i said that ten years ago actually
downtown freddie brown jack sickman or
lenny wilkins yeah absolutely yeah yeah
williams lent yeah that was that was a
lot of fun that i i love the atmosphere
you know because i'll go back to when
george carl was there and
they were they were in the finals
against mike and i thought sean kemp was
the best player on the floor jamal
in the nba finals against the bulls it
was like holy smokes that's a whole
different guy yeah he was out of this
world good you had gary little hamper
and he came and played well towards the
end
uh mj was mj of course but sean kemp was
the one people talked about like you
know what this guy came out of nowhere i
mean the dunk when he went over rodman
and he has some great moments and sean
is great and him and his wife marvin are
great in the community uh even now to
this day they do a lot of a lot of
things that we collaborate on great to
talk to you again as always and uh if so
if the clippers the lakers in golden
state called right now i'll be ready
10 day contract you could go
no doubt about it i'd be ready and i'll
get some buckets oh i know that
did you ever do points per minute in
your career like how many points did you
score
per minute
in your car um
i've never done that that's a good one i
know one year the year my first year in
la i think uh
per
48 i was at like 30. i was pretty high
my first year this year steph and i both
thought we were making an all-star game
we talked about it we both were wrong
because david lee snuck in there and
took it but yeah that first year when i
was with the clippers but i've never
done that is steph a better shooter than
you
he is he absolutely is he he he can get
hot he's better than anybody that's ever
shot the ball and the way he's changed
the game is anybody better than
okay so steph is
on his own level on planet okay anybody
else who's a better shooter than you
that in your opinion
no there's a lot of guys actually ray
allen uh okay miller those guys were
knocked down shooters even kevin durant
he doesn't get the credit he deserves
just as a pure shooter kyrie as well
there's some great shooters out there
but i would say i'm in the top ten
somewhere that's not bad that's not bad
uh great to catch up with you again as
always jamal thanks for joining us thank
you for having me i appreciate it that's
jamal crawford turner sports nba analyst
and three-time winner of the nba sixth
band of the year award